jeremy is a garden snail at first glance
he looks like any other snail
a bit small perhaps and one of his
tentacles is slightly askew
but there's actually something
remarkable about jeremy that makes him
different from the rest
his shell coils to the left
jeremy was discovered by a compost heap
in south west london a retired scientist
spotted the extraordinary mollusk and
made a phone call to this man well this
man being me hi there i'm dr angus
davison i've been researching snails now
for 20 years and jeremy might be the
most unusual snail i've ever encountered
most snail shells pull to the right
jeremy's left coiling shell is exciting
for us because it's extremely rare it's
an opportunity to research whether or
not he can pass his unique traits onto
his offspring eventually we may even be
able to apply our learnings to human
beings
but in order to maximize the research we
need jeremy to reproduce unfortunately
he's not the most seductive suitor
typically a snail sex organs are on the
right side of their head but with jeremy
his genitals are on the left
this little mix-up makes things a bit
awkward we tried pairing jeremy with a
few righties but i had no luck so i went
on the radio to make a casting call
so if you're really looking you find one
of these very rare less coiling smells
and we i'd love to hear from you i was
pessimistic at first
snails like jeremy are one in a hundred
thousand but within a few days the phone
started ringing
hi i'm jade milton in ipswich suffolk a
snail enthusiast with over 300 snails
and this one
lefty might make the perfect match for
jeremy
lefty and jeremy both have left coiling
shells and genitals on the left side
right now the two are resting but once
their energies are high enough we hope
they'll mate and produce some eggs we
are looking for a connection between the
snails and their eggs a discovery could
teach us something about our own
genetics and if not at least jeremy the
left cold snail was able to find love
and that's got to count for something
[Music]
you